j'espère que vous avez tous compris
cette leçon de français et que vous avez
tous maintenant que le présent de
l'indicatif
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment
exemple mohamed vient qu'au cours du
soir pour apprendre le français
mohamed pouvez vous nous raconter une
histoire au présent de l'indicatif
monsieur je peux raconter des histoires
j me promène dans la rue il y en à
nouvoitou qui roule les oiseaux chantent
c'est plein temps il y en a des jeunes
filles jolies du jury il y en a qui rend
dans un bar moi jveux locales aussi via
le patron qui dit non tu n'es pas fort
négative oui c'est très négatif qui
manquent pas pour moi j'ai dit moi je
dis pourquoi je rends pas forme
interrogative qui appelle une réponse
non tout de suite il appelle les flics
mohamed mohamed je vous en prie soigner
votre discours
on raconte qu'ils soient novices - les
flux temps lui qui sont morts dans les
jolis costumes on avec les rues
boulevards et les bâtons ghibli
supplement
tu dis tu dans du papier et j'ai déjà
les playmobil j'ai oublié le pape hier
maison moi même la langue française est
une langue subtil qui vous permet de
vous exprimer avec nuance vous pouviez
dire j'ai oublié mes papiers à mon logis
mais je me fais fort de vous les
apporter dans les plus brefs délais j'ai
pas le temps de parler comme ça tout de
suite il me donnait des coups de pied
dans le cul mon dans la camionnette
roulant chez moi mais mohamed dans le
véhicule vous pouviez vous exprimer
correctement tout j'en ai dit ferme ta
gueule impératif que deux impératifs des
gens comme moi mais je vous en prie
revenez au présent présent présent ils
disent on va te faire une grosse tête tu
auras une sale gueule sur la chute ou
non la saga et il a tout de suite mais
moi j que washington a tous les temps
passé simple passé composé de passes
antérieurs passés futur à ses tweets en
moi mais je vous en prie oublier le
passé je peux pas oublier le passé je me
regarde dans une glace pas bien passé
prenez exemple sur racine notre grand
racing qui savait si bien s'exprimer au
présent écoutez je ne trouve qu'en vous
je ne sais quelle grâce qui me charme
toujours et jamais ne me lasse à vous je
les trouve qu'on vaut je ne sais quelle
grâce qu'elle meeschaert toujours et
jamais ne me lasse je trouve quand vous
je ne sais quelle phrase qu'elle me
semble toujours jamais le mot là je le
trouve comme vous